did New York's favorite scallywag used
to perform in drag New York GOP
Congressman George Santos is accused of
lying about almost everything ever
[Laughter]
to me it's impressive
including his mom being at the World
Trade Center on 9 11 turns out she was
at 7-Eleven on Earth Day
next he'll say he lowered gas prices and
beat up Corn Pop
he's also denying he stole money from a
disabled veteran trying to care for a
sick dog and on top of all that he
reportedly committed the most evil of
evils dressing in drag a drag queen and
former friend of Santos says they met
more than 15 years ago in Brazil Santos
reportedly went by Katara ravachi
him too
I knew we had something in common but
much like me George couldn't handle the
drag queen lifestyle quote he did not
have what it takes to be a professional
George did not have the glamor for that
that's a friend what a catty [ __ ]
Santos tonight he ever performed as a
drag queen calling it the most recent
Obsession from the media and
categorically false but I get his anger
I myself have been accused of making
some embarrassing appearances in very
seedy circumstances very early in my
career
but enough about Fox and Friends
[Laughter]
speaking of cat
they were so nice to me your new best
friends
this guy so I I have to do a little
caveat I have we have reached out to
have him on the show he doesn't
understand that we would treat him with
such
admiration for being so wacky so crazy I
just want to get inside his head
yeah what do you think no that would
certainly be interesting it would yeah
like I've had people in my life were a
pathical pathological liars and even
they like stay away from 9 11 in the
Holocaust yes not this guy but then he's
like drag I would never like he wouldn't
want you know me thinking that you're
not a godly man of God like you are a
liar but I don't think he would he was
obviously not because his friend was
like he didn't have the glamor so
although he did drag he was in fact not
a queen oh
uh Paul uh you must be your your author
as well you've written a number of uh
books you must be fascinated by this
character he is fascinating he's great I
mean he's the most interesting thing in
Congress certainly right I actually hope
he hangs around just so we can watch
what he's going to come up with next
exactly it really does feel like the
simulation yeah the only thing I can
think of is that he leaked this so that
when it time I think he's gonna get
arrested at some point right because
he's got some real Financial
skullduggery yes when he comes out with
the transphobia defense ah because he's
checked every other box he's done just
about everything wrong you could
possibly do and I think that ultimately
he's going to find himself looking at an
arrest who actually you better bring it
gotta get him on the show first yeah I
want him to be my best friend because I
can tell him all my secrets yes because
if he tells other people they won't
believe him yes foreign
[Applause]
he'd be a terrible best friend because
he'd always be asking for money and then
you'd never see it again right tires you
know what
we know we're watching what Republicans
are doing but I'm wondering what would
Dems do I mean they're they never
questioned ilhan Omar and the stuff that
she's been up through
Brotherhood about it
brother husband husband brother
I don't know what I'm saying Tyrus
I have no idea but I I found it
offensive honestly uh they used some
really harsh language in the story they
called him a drag denier
so now denier is just on anything yes it
is you can put it on anything if you
don't wear a hat you're a hat denier
you know if I don't bend down to talk to
you I'm a short denier like this is just
they just going at him and I I it's not
necessary I don't know why he lies
because he literally has one of the most
interesting lives of all time he's been
everywhere he's literally he's done
everything apparently and you know what
what that would you say his name was
caddy [ __ ] was that the performance
name no that was just what oh just a
description of his behavior yes
I for one don't have a problem with
George dressing like a woman in Brazil
do what you got to do bro have a good
time exactly but when you started
talking about he didn't have the talent
for lip syncing oh no driving are you
out of your mind lip syncing is not a
talent people try to walk around in
heels why would I want to because
I walk in heels you want to see it dry
yeah you've got it kid can we get a
picture of Santos you know guy look at
him and I and I look at him and I look
at him and I go not that picture
a picture of him never mind I was going
to say he looks like behind you anyway
there you go
are we sure that's not really Marco
Rubio
with glasses with glasses I mean look
I feel like you look at our current
president and his history of Serial
lying embellishment fabrication
plagiarism yes I think George should
really shoot for the stars exactly
because he might have a future in
politics
it's so funny because like I mean a lot
of a lot of his okay Santos's lies are
absurd and could be so easily checked
like he was he was like a volleyball
star and the president lied about the
circumstances of his own son's death yes
that is checkable and really weird right
and he's president yeah no every day he
makes something up yes none of the
things that Biden is saying it can be
even fact checked it's like crazy
George's lies are funnier yeah the
volleyball star lie is maybe and he was
the star of his volleyball team at a
college that he didn't go to
foreign
maybe I should point this out before we
go we never heard about any of this
until after he won which means this was
all held back to get him out so that the
Republicans he wasn't a threat like
there's no way this lying guy is going
to get in yeah but I think not no I
think that the dam said doesn't matter
if he wins we let this stuff out then
he's gone that's what I think but then
again I think a lot of things
and none of them are true hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else